the first time ever we're blending
live-action seamlessly with your in-game
car & garage all that since you see a
film in real life as you express it as
you play yourself and witness the action
from your own point of view and your
journey will be filled with characters
calling and sending you messages
enticing you into the five ways to play
these moments will pull you through the
game and present you with choices that
determine your path the characters are
your gateway to the story and they will
help you become the ultimate icon here's
two of them spiking on you again with
the block head only today so it's got
some crazy videos Gymkhana tubes have
over 100 million hits it's like I
watching an action movie said this real
you know man who lives for driving with
style slimey's call round corners
jumping and tearing it up and he is all
about impressing can't block and if you
choose he can help you to master you
you're driving to get his attention we
can recreate cans wrong move for move so
matter challenged us to recreate can
style run mood to move but in one take
you need to have some serious car
console to pull those moves off and
ernst and recognition but if you do so
you'll impress can block but do you have
what it takes to become the master of
style it is all up to you how your
journey plays out continue to look to
impress can lock or shift focus to one
of the other icons the choice is yours
so that showed you a taste of one of the
immersive storylines you'll have within
the style however there are four other
ways to play maybe your aim is to
enhance your reputation through
adrenaline fueled driving just like-
walker does or you might be more focused
on creating that perfect customized ride
something that would impress even the
great not guy son you can choose to get
to grips with driving as a crew with
precise movements and drift while trains
and that's what risky devil comes in
or maybe you want to risk it all mess
and escape from the cops and if you do
you will grab the attention of the
infamous Mora Hoshi son every turn in
the game will determine your unique path
find out in November if you can become
the ultimate icon and now let me end
this on the new spectacular Need for
Speed trailer thank you there's some top
grade talent in town who's ready to make
history but this is the next level go on
take it and learn Magnus walkers in time
and we smashed that legendary run a
fitting they'll have to come back at us
check this so you guys doing some fast
runs out there was really impressive you
know about ken Block right Munna today
so we gonna recreate kids run move from
Travis mentioned you worked a couple
cars yourself that's cool use whatever
tool you want I want it ready for not
face on to see before he leaves the city
I'm talking stupid power
what kind of crew you running with these
days
can it all themselves risky devil senior
moves killing it everybody loves an
outlaw someone fighting against system
you gotta ask yourself are you the kind
of drivers in for the rush
you